here on it's lit we spend a lot of time
pontificating on the high cannon of
books
your shakespeares your tolstoys your
erotic beast wars fan fiction
but today we're craving something a
little lighter a little fluffier you
know
novels you pick up just for the sake of
having something quick your beach reads
your airport novels your
books of the month books that while you
might never have to read them for a
seminar or a class or that sweet sweet
clout
somehow manage to dominate most water
cooler discussions around literature
we're talking your dan browns you're
jody picoltz your
where the crawdad sing seriously how has
this book
been on top of every bestseller list for
like about three years straight like i
don't even know what it's about i just
know
it is the mortal enemy of myself and
everyone i know these are your
blockbuster books the best sellers of
the best sellers
and whether or not you read them or turn
your nose up at them for better or worse
they are the tent pulse that support the
publishing industry
so what do we mean when we say best
seller because
i'll be real it's actually a pretty
nebulous term technically i am one
don't worry too much into it according
to american literature professor sarah
garland
the term best seller or best seller as
it is used by the press
is in a sense always hyperbole to call a
book a bestseller already indicates that
the book has come through a series of
decisions about whether to count it
the best seller represents the highest
sales but the highest in sales where and
when
and for how long it won't surprise you
to know that bestseller lists like the
ones you see in the new york times or
usa today
are fairly modern inventions but to
really trace the origin of masked
literature we must go back to look at
everybody's favorite fulcrum of literary
history
the printing press so prior to its
invention in the mid-15th century
books were a precious commodity that
took serious time effort and money to
create and to buy
but even with the printing press
bringing down costs of bookmaking most
people if they could read and afford
books
usually owned mass-produced prayer books
or heavily spiritual titles
books like john bunyan's pilgrim
progress a whip-cracking 100 000 words
of heavy religious metaphor about
perdition
and hell you know a fun beach read all
this is to say that popular books then
were functional must-haves for the soul
and they were usually short very short
for production costs
which ironically meant the bible itself
didn't particularly sell well until the
19th century
but in the 18th century as the novel
began to take off literary critics
noticed almost cult-like devotion to
titles by authors like voltaire
whose candide reportedly sold a then
staggering 20
000 copies in its first month and
gerta's the sorrows of young werther
which was so popular it had merchandise
from prince to porcelain to perfume
your move twilight promotional body
spray
america didn't get hip to this until the
mid 19th century when publishers started
realizing they could gamify the industry
by following suit and also publishing
books to the taste of audiences
and not necessarily by what the
intelligentsia gained to disperse to the
rabble
and then the real american bestsellers
like uncle tom's cabin start flooding
bookstores
books that dealt with highly topical
highly emotional subject matter
became must-reads that everyone could
get their hands on because of highly
strategic
but bold publishing maneuvers but unlike
say uncle tom's cabin
most of these blockbusters eventually
fell into obscurity the first published
american bestseller list appeared in
1895 in a new monthly magazine called
the bookman this magazine was imitating
its london counterpart
also called the bookman which had been
publishing a bestseller list for several
years
and used sales information from the
leading bookstores in 16 cities
later extended to 30 cities in the
united states and canada to gain
information for its list of the six
best-selling titles for each town and
then in 1931 came the absolute game
changer
the new york times best seller list
initially it only had a grand total of
five fiction
and four non-fiction books on it and it
only reflected numbers from the city of
new york itself but by the 1950s the
controversial proprietary ranking method
had become the list for tracking book
sales and by the 1970s
bookstore chains began using business
models that highlighted books with four
words that have changed everything
new york times bestseller so despite
competition from movies and television
more people were actually reading novels
than ever as literary critic peter
swirsky has highlighted
more than half of all of the books ever
published came out after the first
hydrogen bomb
more than half of all wordsmiths whoever
put pen to paper did so after the birth
of tv
the number of new titles released each
year in the united states quadrupled
between 1950 and 1991.
so now that we're here you might be
wondering how does one get their book
on a best seller list how did you do it
crawdads
does it have to be a masterpiece of
emotion wit and craft
so if you're thinking that publishers
decide who's a bestseller before
anything even goes to print
you're you're kind of right according to
very important
lawyer agent morton l janklow
self-fulfilling prophecies play a large
part in book publishing
what makes a publisher decide that a
first printing should be a hundred
thousand copies rather than sixty five
thousand
if a publisher buys a book for five
thousand dollars it'll be a miracle if
anything happens to it
because in the mind of the publisher it
has already failed
well let's create a hypothetical author
his name is jimmy squibbles and he is a
high-profile pocky beauty influencer
and he's ready to go ahead with his
debut novel hype house bloodbath
so let's put aside talent and suppose he
has a good literary agent who manages to
net him in advance from a big six big
five
big four publisher say one and a half
million dollars
jimmy squibbles is in luck because the
higher the advance the more his
publisher will push hype house blood
bath harder from a marketing standpoint
which means more mainstream coverage
which translates to more sales
argues professor of sociology laura j
miller the self-fulfilling nature of the
list
thus comes from the fact that the
reading public is constantly bombarded
with information about
and opportunities and incentives to buy
books on the list
and buy they do and this works sort of
that push has to coincide with some sort
of demand in the market
a good recent example of this is janine
cummins american dirt
which focuses on the topical topic of
central american migration
to this proud land
of dirt american dirt got a seven-figure
advance from its publisher flatiron
books
and not one but two reviews in the new
york times which is
exceedingly rare and while one of those
reviews was glowing
the other absolutely trashed it said new
york times book critic parole seagal
i found myself flinching as i read not
from the perils the characters face but
from the mauling the english language
receives lydia's expression is one luca
has never seen before
and he fears it might be permanent it's
as if seven fishermen have cast their
hooks into her from different directions
and they're all pulling at once
one from the eyebrow one from the lip
another at the nose
one from the cheek yes of course that
expression and once that type of
negative publicity was coupled with a
huge
outpouring of backlash regarding
cummin's handling of a sensitive subject
matter while not being latina herself
well who knows as in the case of
american dirt backlash can actually
boost sales numbers
a lot some people were curious and a lot
of other people just wanted to support
the book to stick it to the woke brigade
that took
issue with it in the first place
controversy legit or manufactured
is extremely lucrative american dirt is
one of the top selling titles of 2020.
so good job
one of the other big vehicles for
pushing bestsellers are book club lists
things like oprah's book club for
example which has single-handedly made
many debut
or relatively unknown authors into stars
it even made leo tolstoy's 1877 novel
anna karenina into a bestseller in 2004.
fordham university marketing professor
al greco estimates that sales of oprah
editions aka
book slapped with oprah's book club
stamp of approval on the cover
have sold a total of 55 million copies
in the u.s alone
while book publicist patricia eisemann
has referred to oprah's book club as
a blessing from the book gods and while
the list does tend to skew towards a
female audience which probably explains
why noted pleasant person jonathan
friends and pitched a fit when his novel
the corrections was added to it if jimmy
squibbles and his publisher don't care
about being marketed to
women then getting on her list is a good
thing
jonathan there are of course less
scrupulous means of getting books into
people's hands
a few years ago there was the
controversy of handbook for mortals
author lanny serum
buying up her own books through third
parties and landing at the top of the
new york times list for y a fiction
before being removed once she got called
out this happens more often than you
might think but usually with non-fiction
and when it does happen the new york
times puts a little dagger next to it on
the list
to show that it's a little fishy and
it's probably not legit but we're gonna
put it on the list anyway
like hey there's been shapiro he had a
book come out the very same day mine did
look
check there's there's the dagger but
here's the other let's acknowledge
caveat
being a bestseller does not always
equate success let's return to our
friend jimmy squibbles
he's got that advance he's gotten
mainstream coverage his novel hype house
bloodbath
has been added to a bunch of book lists
and hey let's even say he already has a
huge built-in audience as a pokemon
beauty guru influencer and it's enough
for him to get on both the hardcover
list
and the combined print and e-fiction new
york times list for several weeks
success well no none of that means his
book has found a staying audience nor
does it necessarily mean that he's
earned back that huge advance
and unfortunately for jimmy squibbles
the math is not on his side
with a standard boilerplate royalty rate
and an msrp of
let's say 28 you might be thinking oh
okay so he only needs to sell 1.5
million divided by
28 which is about 53 000 books
and he's a pocky influencer with 20
million youtube subs and 9 billion
instagram followers that should be easy
right well no that's not how royalties
work
with an msrp of 28 his royalties are
only going to be a tiny percentage of
that
he actually needs to sell closer to
maybe around 360 000 books
and that's a lot of books those are some
like michelle obama numbers so if jimmy
squibble sells 20 to 30
000 copies per week for about 10 weeks
that is not only more than 99
of books that will ever sell it's also
nowhere near enough for him to earn out
his advance
and if interest in hype house bloodbath
peters out then he will probably never
earn it out
so that book was technically a
bestseller but not exactly a success
don't read into this and so like so many
19th century authors who had their
moment in the sun
jimmy squibbles and hype house bloodbath
fade into obscurity
never to reach the heights of the sun
also rises or
the great gatsby year where the crawdad
seriously who was reading this book
mom stop all this sounds labyrinthine or
intimidating for any aspiring author out
there well
there is some truth to that book
publishing trends are finicky and wild
with publishers hedging their bets on
what they
think will sell and not necessarily with
any regard to a writer's talent if hype
house bloodbath becomes the next
american classic with a multi-million
dollar movie deal starring logan paul
you can be sure that literary agents
will be looking for manuscripts that are
similar to hype house bloodbath to hop
on that sweet sweet pocky influencer
gravy train
but it need not always be like this it's
not always large publishers that pick
authors out of obscurity
there have been many notable titles that
have found larger audiences via a
growing indie publishing industry or
through less orthodox means
margaret atwood's first published book
of poetry double persephone
was published as a pamphlet by a small
press in 1961
winning her an ej pratt medal andy wears
the martian which sat on the best seller
list for 76 weeks
19 of those at number one which is
nothing like them crawdads but hey good
job andy
started as a series of blog posts that
he compiled self-published and sold for
99 cents
lisa genova's still alice was originally
self-published on a digital
self-publishing
platform iuniverse with copies literally
being sold out of the trunk of her car
and fifty shades of grey
yeah point being that getting a book
published is incredibly difficult to say
nothing about turning it into a hit
and this is not to dunk on authors who
do make it onto the list
hello or suggest that there's no merit
to a best-selling novel
for those who do make it it's often the
result of years of sculpting away at an
idea
hundreds of hours of revising and
revising and completely rewriting out of
a labor of love or devotion to
storytelling but more often it's just
who the publisher thinks should be there
sorry about it so good luck jimmy
squibbles i hope hype house bloodbath
does well
but uh it probably wouldn't hurt to
throw some singing crawdads
in there or whatever that book is about
i don't know i don't care
you